police in our great ally of Saudi Arabia
have arrested a woman for wearing what
they describe as a miniskirt in public
and on video the kingdom is furious
because it's conservative Islamic dress
code has been violated they've not
confirmed the authenticity of the
following video clip on ABC and a number
of other media outlets which has been it
was originally posted to snapchat
ultimately on Twitter but it does appear
to show the woman in question in a skirt
and a black crop top as many have
described we are playing the video for
our television audience she was
described detained in the capital city
of Riyadh for wearing what are described
as immodest clothes and the case has
been sent to the public prosecutor she
shared the video on snapchat many people
outraged some people outraged because
this isn't even a miniskirt many people
are saying meanwhile there are still
efforts towards progress being made in
the kingdom the government announced
that girls would be allowed to play
sports in school Wow
they would also be allowed to attend gym
class and the religious police are no
longer officially allowed to arrest
people but they can still recommend
arrests to the regular police total and
utter nightmare and I don't even get why
they need to go so crazy over this stuff
given that it's all religiously based if
a skirt or a woman driving or playing
sports really makes God angry wouldn't
God just dole out the punishments for
wearing skirts or whatever as God sees
fit like why do you need such an
apparatus of religious police and
special prosecutors and all this BS if
God is going to punish people who do the
wrong thing this behavior is certainly
not deserving of major weapons deals
from the United States that I can tell
you and just this incredible glaring
hypocrisy that exists in terms of the
American diplomatic relationship with
Saudi Arabia despite their connections
to funding terror and despite the fact
that they threw Wahhabism are one of the
most extreme sects of Islam in the world
but we say hey they're our ally because
we've got these shared interests
instability for for oil purposes and
they buy a lot of American weapons and
that's good for the military-industrial
complex I've been saying this for I
don't even know how long it's been at
this point ten years I don't even know
it's one of the most immoral alliances
that your United States has and
prosecution for a miniskirt not even a
miniskirt according to people who know
about that type of thing
sad very very low energy today's episode
of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS